in only a few days
this group of students will no longer be
sharing an apartment in the city of
Verona sh two of the groups Turkish
members are being forced to leave Russia
on one of their last evenings together
Igor and his friends think about how
everything changed they suddenly became
enemies of the Russian state the
landlord threw one of my friends out of
his apartment only because he's Turkish
another was forced to leave University a
third friend was detained by police they
took his money and threatened him since
then we've been living in fear that
we'll have to leave the country for
whatever reason the authorities will
come up with some reason Kakuta pretty
nice atlas pasta pasta naan process only
go really they called us and said that
effective immediately they will always
have to know where we are every hour kai
is d Ches foreign ash is a university
town five hours from Moscow young people
come here from all over the world two
thousand of them in 2015 alone but since
the crisis erupted between Russia and
Turkey more and more Turkish students
are being expelled from university
allegedly because they can't handle the
workload anymore
no one from augurs university wanted to
talk to us instead they sent a statement
in which the school director said that
nine out of ten Turkish students had
been forced to leave in the past two
weeks
he denied politics played any role we're
now afraid to tell anyone were Turkish
people stare at us if we speak Turkish
together it's not very nice jenia
children not someone get it I really
don't want to leave Russia but all my
friends are no longer here I'm not truly
afraid but I don't feel comfortable here
anymore and as soon as I have an
opportunity I'll be leaving too I'll go
to Europe or somewhere else
it's just pi I hope he really
undesirable persons that's what the
Turkish students have become in just a
few weeks ago they were considered
Russia's best friends Turks in Russia
via the lives have changed irrevocably
older the Russian Education Ministry
said there would be no official
sanctions taken against Turkish students
there are reports of harassment and
intimidation in the community therefore
most of Turkish students for example
here in Verona SH were forced to end
their studies and to leave the country